des fois il ya des petits accessoires
comme ça qu'ils payent pas de mine mais
qui sont justes ouf
et qui vous donne un petit truc en plus
et ça on va en parler les amis de ça on
va en parler on va en parler mais juste
après d'intro et salue les gens derrière
l'écran c'est françois pour la chaîne
explique mans encore je suis ravi de
vous retrouver comme à chaque fois pour
une nouvelle vidéo et si vous êtes
nouveau ici là sachez qu'on parle de
création de vidéos de tournage de
montage de matos bref tous ces trucs là
qui sont hyper intéressant si vous vous
intéressez la vidéo donc c'est peut-être
éventuellement le moment de cliquer sur
le petit bouton s'abonner par ce qui
aura forcément des choses qui vont vous
intéressez sur cette chaîne est
particulièrement route on va parler d'un
tout petit accessoire mais qui est
vraiment sympa que j'ai découvert ya pas
très longtemps et je ne vais pas faire
durer le suspense plus longtemps cet
accessoire c'est un filtre diffuseur de
la marque momments mais vous allez me
dire mais qu'est ce que c'est françois
un filtre diffuseurs et bien c'est un
filtre qui l'avenir se visser sur
l'optique qu'on va mettre sur sa caméra
là actuellement elle est vissé sur nous
et si c'est un petit peu comme en vie
serait un filtre ndé sauf que ce filtre
là il a un usage tout autre le filtre
diffuseur son objectif c'est comme son
nom l'indiqué de diffuser un petit peu
la lumière d'ailleurs si on le regarde
de près on a l'impression que ce filtre
il est légèrement floue et l'idée en
fait c'est que la lumière vienne
rebondir un petit peu dans ce filtre à
l'intérieur pour venir se diffuser
légèrement et adoucir un petit peu
l'image mais pourquoi est ce qu'on
voudrait rajouter du flou sur notre
image parce que grosso modo c'est ce que
ça fait ça va légèrement foot et l'image
et bien tout simplement parce que si en
photo on va aimer beaucoup avoir une
image sharp net détaillé en vidéo pour
un look
attention attention attention un petit
peu cinéma trop donné pts et tu la
netteté en gros les optiques modernes
sont très très nettes sont traîtres
écharpes sont très détaillées et
précises et pour un look sympa en vidéo
et ben parfois c'est un peu trop d'où
l'idée du filtre diffuseurs et c'est une
technique et énormément utilisé au
cinéma je les encourage à faire
attention un petit peu aux lumières aux
éclairages qui a dans les séries et les
films que vous regardez comme vous
pouvez le voir derrière moi les lumières
elles ont une espèce de petit halo comme
s'il y avait une légère brume autour
pour diffuser un petit peu la lumière et
ben c'est le filtre qui fait ça et on
retrouve ça dans énormément de films et
séries actuellement et depuis très très
longtemps
alors pourquoi je suis parti sur ce
filtre signer blum de moumen tout
simplement parce que la référence en
terme de filtres diffuseur c'est un fils
ce qu'on appelle le black promised mais
qui coûte quand même relativement cher
ici m'ont même si l'on fait un truc
assez cool avec un filtre de qualité qui
démarre à 49 euros ou dollars je sais
plus enfin grosso modo c'est à peu près
la même chose
et autant dire que pour un filtre
diffuseur c'est rien 1 franchement c'est
vraiment rien ils le font en 20 % qui
est le filtre que j'utilise là pour les
images d'illustration et ils le font
également 10% donc un peu moins de flou
un peu moins de brume un peu moins de
myst moi j'ai choisi plutôt le 20 %
parce que je voulais avoir vraiment le
plus possible de cet effet pour pouvoir
juger si c'était intéressant il existe
dans plusieurs diamètres en fonction des
optiques que vous utilisez moi j'ai pris
le plus gros le 82 mm parce que je sais
que ma plus grosse optique elle est sur
un filetage de 82 mm mais j'ai pris ces
petites choses là ici là qui sont des
adaptateurs de la visserie tout
simplement qu'ils vont me permettre
d'adapter mon filtre sur n'importe
quelle optique que j'ai déjà fait exprès
la plus grosse qui était un petit peu
plus cher d'ailleurs soit dit en passant
mais bon voilà ça reste quand même
raisonnable donc ce filtre je le trouve
particulièrement cool et d'ailleurs je
suis pas le seul
ah bah tiens d'ailleurs victor tu tombe
bien est ce que tu pourrais nous parler
un petit peu de ce filtre toi aussi
puisque tu l'utilisent avec un coup
franc son moi je le trouve plutôt cool
ce petit filtre de diffusion j'utilise
maintenant pour toutes mes vidéos face
comme sur youtube et c'est vrai que ça
donne l'aspect que j'aime beaucoup un
petit look cinéma comme on dit qui est
vraiment sympa pour expliquer un petit
peu concrètement qu'est-ce qui fait ce
filtre de diffusion à quoi ça sert
qu'est-ce qui fait concrètement sur
votre objectif
en fait il va permettre d'adoucir toute
l'image adoucir les détails donnés ce
petit halo autour des lumières qui est
assez sympa tout en conservant le
contraste de l'image et la netteté et
c'est vrai que comme l'a dit françois ça
permet entre autres de donner un aspect
un peu plus doux au visage ça permet de
casser un petit peu la netteté qui est
très présente sur les appareils qu'on
utilise aujourd'hui pour filmer puisqu'à
la base des appareils photo et donc en
gros avec ces filtres de diffusion on va
pouvoir dit
la lumière à faire quelque chose d'un
petit peu plus doux et donnait
finalement un look organique directement
avec la caméra sans passer par des
effets de post production
ce qui fait que notre image en soit elle
n'est pas du tout dégradé d'ailleurs
pour vous montrer les faits en direct je
vais venir le davis et hop
et là vous voyez un petit peu le rendu
de la caméra sans le filtre est là si je
le remets regardez bien la petite
lumière qui est derrière
hop voilà un petit peu le look que ça
donne et c'est vrai que ce filtre il
donne un aspect un petit peu vintage qui
rappelle les anciennes caméra qui
filmait avec des pellicules et moi
j'aime bien ce look là je trouve que
c'est pas à utiliser forcément dans
toutes les circonstances et dans tous
les types de production mais dans des
trucs un peu sympa dans des clips de la
fiction ou des trucs où on veut donner
un petit style à l'image ben je trouve
que quand ça fait travailler alors par
contre comme francoual un petit peu
évoquée il ya certaines situations où le
filtre je vous recommande pas du tout
d'utiliser la première situation c'est
lorsque vous avez des lumières trop
forte puisque en gros comme voulait dit
tout à l'heure le filtre y viennent
étaler toute la lumière donc si vous
avez trop de lumière je vais vous
montrer un petit exemple avec la lumière
du téléphone eh ben ça va faire un truc
pas très sympa parce que si on a juste
la lumière comme ça bon voilà ça fait un
petit effet glowy un peu sympa par
contre si je vais mettre la lumière trop
près de l'objectif
ben vous voyez que les faits il est pas
génial par contre il ya certaines
conditions où c'est vraiment génial de
l'utiliser c'est par exemple la nuit
quand il ya des petites lumières comme
ça qu'ils viennent briller avec ce
filtre qui vient de faire leur petit
halo de lumière
vraiment ça donne un look qui est
vraiment super sympa ce filtre ça peut
être vraiment une super alternative
donc je vous le recommande merci à toi
victor je mets ta chaîne en lien dans la
description aller voir les amis ce petit
jeune il
il est bien il est bien bien bien donc
pour résumer ce filtre je les utilisais
sur plusieurs prod récemment vraiment
j'en suis hyper content la seule
contrainte qui va y avoir c'est que si
on vise directement une source de
lumière
là on a un écran quasi-blanche
impossible quasiment impossible d'avoir
des petits frères des petites réflexions
des petites voilà ces petits défauts
qu'on a sur certaines vidéos quand on
fait un direct vers le soleil avec le
petit coucher de soleil là en gros c'est
impossible les contre-jours sont quasi
impossibles à gérer ça va être du blanc
de total en dehors de ça vraiment sur
toute la ligne ça donne un look jeu
vraiment très très très typé très
particulier ça peut être un look vintage
si vraiment on retouche assez peu en
colo si on redescend pas mal les ombres
comme ce que je fais ici par exemple on
se retrouve avec quelque chose d'assez
sympa dépôts qui vont être beaucoup plus
homogène beaucoup moins détaillé
beaucoup moins textures et c'est quand
même pas mal et on va avoir vraiment
cette sensation de myst voilà de petite
brume sur les lumières que j'aime
vraiment vraiment vraiment beaucoup
c'est pas grand chose mais ça fait une
petite différence que je trouve vraiment
très très très intéressant alors bien
sûr il ya d'autres marques
un peter mc kinnon il a sorti un filtre
md plus mist mais bon ça coûtera une
relativement cher sachant que le ciné
blum de moman
il a aussi un filetage ça veut dire que
je vais pouvoir venir vie c'est par
dessus un filtre md si j'en ai besoin et
vu que des filtres année j'en ai déjà
j'ai pas forcément besoin d'acheter 1
mde plus un mystère plus un diffuseur
donc là vraiment je trouve qu'on fait
une plutôt bonne affaire avec ce filtre
la joue mais rien dans la description
cette vidéo n'est pas sponsorisé ce
n'est pas un lien traquer c'est juste
pour le plaisir de vous partager ce
petit découverte que j'ai fait et
d'ailleurs si ça vous fait plaisir à
vous aussi vous pouvez mettre le
traditionnel coup deux blaster sur le
pouce en l'air qui se situe juste en
dessous de cette vidéo pouvait aller
voir d'autres vidéos de la chaîne vous
abonner et soyons fou hein pourquoi pas
et moi je vous dis les amis rester
curieux et à très bientôt pour une
prochaine vidéo
j'ai tourné un clip avec ce filtre
tarbes vraiment qu'ils sortent parce que
ça va ça va vous plaire mais là c'est
encore un concours de travail et tout il
y aura une sortie officielle tout ça
mais mais voilà je suis un petit peu
tombé amoureux de ce filtre il faut le
dire il faut l'avouer voilà ces jeux
c'est dit c'est fait voilà